[Music]
[Applause]
this is the IBM personal computer it was
the most advanced computing machine ever
created however this isn't a story about
a computer but a story about when a
computer stops working and the man who
created a way to start it all over the
man who invented control-alt-delete
let's get into it
hi I'm dr. Dave Bradley but you can call
me dr. Dave back in 1980 I worked on the
IBM personal computer my particular job
on the IBM PC was writing the basic
input/output system even with an elite
team of engineers and designers not
everything goes smoothly when you're
building a computer we had programs that
ran most of the time but when they
failed the only way to reset the system
was turn the power off wait awhile turn
the power back on and it would go
through a very long self-test but the
system might die every 5 to 10 minutes
what he needed was a way to shortcut the
restart process one of the things we
discussed was putting a reset button on
it but if you put it on the system board
there was a chance that you could hit it
by mistake and all your data gets lost
so what we did was came up with a three
key sequence who would reset to this
computer and new coding hits by mistake
a single control key a single Alt key
and then all the way over at the right
hand side a single delete key
when you hit that control-alt-delete
you're deleting everything that you're
working on right now and starting new I
was also able to skip over many of the
tests so instead of taking a minute or
two it was 10 or 15 seconds but it
wasn't a big deal at the time it was
like number 17 on the list of a hundred
different things I had to fix even
though it was built only as a
development tool programmers began
incorporating the feature into their
applications from there it was released
into the wild but didn't immediately
reach pop culture status for years
it was no big deal and then at the 20th
anniversary of the IBM PC that's when
control officer Lee became sort of a
cultural icon it was the simplest and
easiest way to fix your problem hit
control-alt-delete start all over
despite all this dr. Dave doesn't think
much of this contribution to computing
history I get lots of things with IBM
but all everybody remembers is
control-alt-delete but I'll take that
the fame of control-alt-delete means
that I worked on a very successful
product and I'm very proud of having
been able to do that
[Music]
there are 43 quintillion possible
combinations now imagine you have no
websites no books and no one to show you
how to solve it
because you invented it but you didn't
invent the rubik's cube this guy did
my name is anaerobic was born here in
this beautiful city of Budapest it was
1974 30 year-old Erno Rubik was just
beginning his career in academia I was
lecturing design and architecture very
similar in age with the students I was
very ambitious to find new ways to teach
them especially about space and three
dimension
I made a cube as a teaching game and for
my son learn something from it once the
physical cube was put together
ernõ began hunting for its secrets and
the question was not it is possible to
solve it but the tension was it is
possible to find a method to do that
there is 26 small cubes it looks the
same but in the structure of the cube
they have different rules
ernõ racked his brain first strategy
twisting and turning the cube in his
hands and his head to unlock his
creation after I started to understand
the nature of this action the movement I
found the way for a solution it's not
that straight away and after a month he
cracked the code but the story doesn't
end there
I had the feeling the potential of the
object I found it very simple to
manufacture the result of that it can be
an object what is available for everyone
in 1980 Erna would finally bring his
cube to the world and from there it took
off becoming one of the best-selling
toys of all time because of the content
of the cube the world discovered is not
a gadget it's something that is more
valuable more long life and after almost
40 years Rubik's Cube has seen a
comeback with hundreds of calm
tuitions every year across the world for
ernõ the cube that bears his name is
more than just a toy it's a reminder to
never give up
there is always way for a solution at
all their way to find something else
something new something different or
final result of you if today is not
everything is good it's something
tomorrow can not be better depend on you
[Music]
[Applause]
there is a wise old Japanese saying the
nail that sticks out gets hammered down
well down in Tokyo there's one nail that
sticks out just about as far as you can
imagine an inventor known across the
country a mad genius with a staggering
number of patents tons Angwin imagine II
say Kevin yeah Thomas Alva Edison knock
somebody up that includes a wig for self
defense meet you shiro Nakamatsu you may
notice his name is spelled mahkumat he
dropped the letter you because he says
an 8 letter name is easier to remember
but he still wants you to pronounce it
you got a duck dr. Nakamatsu score key
inventions brought him worldwide
recognition inventions like the Chianti
on booths with springs that put an extra
bounce in your step
there's dr. Nakamatsu siree Breck's it
looks like a lazy boy but the doc says
the darn thing enhances brain power then
there's the gold golf putter that paints
when you strike the ball Oh would you
look at that you know you've made it
when the streets are named after you but
make no mistake dr. Nakamatsu inventions
aren't all noisy golf clubs and bouncy
shoes he claims to have invented the
floppy disk that's right that floppy
disc retractable landing gear a widely
used kerosene pump and even the digital
watch to maintain his hyper creativity
dr. Nakamatsu keeps his mind and body in
shape
that lightweight inventor Thomas Edison
said genius is 1% inspiration and 99%
perspiration is that your secret dr.
Nakamatsu yeah Ezra desperation Donna no
Sara nuestros dozle khodataeva con todas
scene oh yeah
static guru matter camel toe toe toe
calving agenda changes national Abba
tere bin Laden Patoka Jeon abandoned
temple Sunnis Shia Dona Dona moças Cana
dynamic Ramadi that's my new motto menu
it's more Beethoven died gonna dice and
actual started as Muhammad Ahmad Remus
sir a demo domina by erroneously aku not
anonymous free osaka-jo the dairy my
optimism
mrs. no not animal to Ho Hos
[Music]
mizuna Panama where most of the sons
Oona nonny Marin economist madoka kyono
cameo as mesh mesh day sorry amo te le
mo da Costa huzzah - Desiree moment old
Oh Yoko doe at Emma's cinema no détendre
Gobi omedetou minimal tonight Oh sigh so
Tina's Oh Madonna no day sinico hot
reservoir dr. Cotterill q you cannot
remain horse textual is your new machine
gun cried master attack schewe
tending conscious master dr. Nakamatsu
saw the cancer as an opportunity it was
his greatest challenge to invent his way
out of an impossible corner he developed
his own personal cancer treatment this
includes a meticulously documented diet
and a new invention to fight the cancer
II called the Gangan robe
the doctors gave him one year to live
that was five years ago
[Music]
but actua quue sudesna test a nose into
a motor Mason what actua rocket so stay
services - inna yuh green juice an not a
tequila so dose oh no sir no ganado t
simple DoCoMo Shamus Nkomo add actua
cinema day oddsmakers - oh not Inanna at
actua Stoughton Oh Sergio matamata tight
at immortal parodies selenium they
attack us yes
[Music]
there's this amazing picture of my
coworker it's him reading a Ninja
Turtles book lying next to a super
soaker when the super soaker came out it
was a game changer the slogan wetter is
better was essentially a mantra for kids
during summer break so when I went to
Atlanta to interview the guy responsible
for all that I had to show him the photo
Lonnie Johnson invented the super soaker
back in 1982 but that is not his only
invention I have over 100 patents
everything from the nerf gun to a
thermoelectric energy converter he also
worked on NASA's Galileo mission to
Jupiter and alongside the US military
the first Super Soaker actually I made
in my shop in my basement in the
evenings when I would come home from
work and at the time I was actually
working with a stealth bomber program
back when it was highly classified and I
actually couldn't even tell my wife what
I was working on during the daytime it
was that that top-secret the original
name for the Super Soaker was the drench
er we ran into a challenge regarding the
name because another inventor claimed
that till we changed the name the Super
Soaker just to avoid having to deal with
that Super Soaker is definitely a way
better name when he started Lani wasn't
trying to create a toy for kids I was
working on a new type of heat pump that
would use water as a working fluid
instead of freon and I was experimenting
with signals that I had machined and I
shot a stream of water across the
bathroom and I thought geez maybe I
should put this hard science stuff aside
and work on something fun like a water
gun
this still works and this brings me back
to a previous point Lonnie Johnson is a
super genius scientist this is his lab
and this is what he's working on now
yeah right now I'm working on advanced
battery technology my goal is to develop
a battery that will store about three
times the energy of a lithium-ion
battery in comparison the Super Soaker
might not seem as hard science but it
was still a really really important
invention
[Music]